madame gonthier-maurin vous avez la
parole
la présidente madame la ministre mes
chers collègues
avec cet amendement nous souhaitons
permettre à cette loi d'être en parfaite
cohérence avec les objectifs qui sont
affichés dans celui de réaffirmation du
collège unique parce que les mots ont un
sens et que nous avons réussi à
progresser ensemble à l'article 7 qui
concerne les objets les objectifs fixés
à la scolarité obligatoire conservait le
dima dispositif de pré orientation entre
en contradiction avec ses objectifs et
l'esprit de refondation que ce texte
veut afficher
d'autant que ce dispositif est loin
d'avoir fait ses preuves et n'a pour
tout dire que peu fait recette
comme j'ai pu le constater dans le
travail que j'ai réalisé comme
rapporteur pour avis sur le budget de
l'enseignement professionnel et comme
l'a récemment confirmé le rapport de la
cour des comptes sur l'orientation au
collège cela s'explique notamment par le
fait que du fait de la baisse des
redoublements arrive en fin de collège
les élèves plus jeunes qu'avant de plus
compte tenu des dispositions prévues à
l'article 33 sont mattia me paraît
d'autant plus inutile
merci madame la présidente
l'amendement premier rectifié n'est pas
défendu tombe le 77ème alain ferrand
sets identiques d'ailleurs oui merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je je j'évoquerai
devant vous le 77 et le soixante dix
huit si vous me le permettez je ne vais
pas reprendre mes arguments de ce matin
pour autant j'avais eu le sentiment que
monsieur le ministre était attentif à ma
demande encore une fois il n'est pas
question de faire travailler des jeunes
qu'ils n'auraient pas à la fois acquis
le socle commun un maître de stage est
un vrai parcours signalés mais
simplement de faire en sorte que des
gens qui auraient alors anniversaire au
mois d'octobre par exemple ne soit pas
laissé au bord du chemin jusqu'à la
rentrée suivante tout simplement merci
madame serra je considère que vous avez
défendu
78 également merci monsieur gendre le de
rectifier bis
excusez moi la présidente
oui il s'agit d'un amendement de repli
nous souhaitons supprimés l'alinéa 5 de
l'article 38
rappelons que l'article 62 22 1 du code
du travail permet à un jeune ayant 15
ans au cours d'année civile d'avoir la
qualité d'apprenti ci justifie avoir
accompli la scolarité du premier cycle
de l'enseignement secondaire
l'alinéa 5 veut supprimer la mention au
cours de l'année civile pour venir la
notion strict de 15 ans révolus
ceci nous paraît trop rigide et nous
souhaitons qu'un jeune qui a accompli
donc ça score était 2 premier cycle même
s'il n'a pas encore les 15 ans révolus
puisse obtenir la qualité d'apprenti
merci monsieur legendre le 146 rectifié
n'est pas défendu mais il est identique
aux deux rectifié bis donc il sera mis
aux mises aux voix
madame ferrat a défendu le 78 très bien
donc je vais demander à madame au nom de
la commission madame la rapporteure son
avis sur cette série d'amendements
alors
merci madame la présidente commençons
par l'amendement 128 de madame gonthier
maurin le dima est considérablement
affaiblie par le projet de loi tel qu'il
nous est proposé puisqu'il ne peut plus
être entrepris qu'à 15 ans révolus et
doit viser la maîtrise du socle commun
l'amendement modifie de façon abrupte le
code du travail
sambi alors dans les partenaires sociaux
pour fermer la possibilité à un jeune de
15 ans ayant terminé le collège d'entrée
en apprentissage
donc pour cette raison nous émettons un
avis défavorable
l'amendement de madame ferrat madame
ferrat à poser une question ou amis je
pense que le gouvernement répondra est
autrement l'amendement bien sûr
défavorable les amendements similaires
qui visent tous les mêmes objets
défavorable pour donc le 38 146 et 78
dames le rapporteur je vais donc
demander l'avis du gouvernement sur
cette série d'amendements
madame le ministre l'avait madame la
présidente nous sommes d'accord avec
l'avis de la commission
il est certain que ce dispositif dit
marc n'a pas fait la preuve de son
efficacité
nous croyons que dans beaucoup de cas ce
n'est pas l'intérêt du jeune de partir
trop tôt en apprentissage on a précisé
qu' effectivement il faut qu'ils
puissent avoir acquis le socle commun
donc effectivement peut-être qu'en
pratique si c'est un jeune qui a 15 ans
trois quarts et qui a acquis le socle
commun on peut envisager des
assouplissements
mais en l'état il me semble que il n'est
pas utile de le mentionner dans la loi
est pratiquement l'avis de la commission
nous semble un équilibre raisonnable
entre ceux qui veulent que les jeunes
partent en apprentissage trop tôt et
ceux qui sont absolument hostile à à
cela dans certains cas il peut être
utile et c'est peut-être une bonne chose
pour un jeune
partir en apprentissage mais nous
croyons que tant qu'il peut essayer
d'acquérir les éléments du socle commun
et approfondir sa connaissance les
matières fondamentales c'est préférable
pour lui merci madame la ministre madame
ferrand oui et pardonnez moi d'être
aussi tenace je crains de ne pas bien
avoir entendu madame la ministre
n'at-elle pas 10 15 ans trois quarts
n'ont cessé 14 ans a passé 14 ans trois
quarts et non pas 15 ans trois quarts
voilà j'ai bien voilà merci merci pour
cette précision très bien donc je vais
mettre aux voix
l'amendement 128 présenté par madame
gonthier maurin qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui et pour qui et pour
merci qui est contre merci abstentions
l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement de madame ferrat le 77 qui
est aussi le même que l'amendement
premier rectifié deux avis défavorables
qui est pour merci contre merci
abstentions c'est le moment sont pas
adopté l'amendement de rectifier biz
présentée par monsieur legendre deux
avis défavorables qui est pour
merci contre 6 abstentions
ils ne sont pas adoptées le 78 présenté
par madame ferrat deux avis défavorables
qui est pour
merci contre merci il n'est pas adopté
en arrivant à un moment ça 130 qui est
présenté par notre rapporteur au nom de
la commission d'amm la présidente c'est
un amendement de coordination dans le
code général des impôts merci madame le
rapporteur madame la ministre votre avis
merci je vais le mettre aux voix
l'amendement de la commission avec un
avis favorable du gouvernement qui pour
merci contre l'abstention la maman 530
est adopté nous en arrivons au vote sur
l'article 38 y at il une explication de
vote
je n'en vois pas je vais donc mettre aux
voix l'article qui est pour l'article 38
merci contre merci abstentions merci
l'article 38 est adoptée après l'article
38 un amendement 177 présenté par dans
la bouche ou madame la présidente madame
la présidente de la commission madame
les rapporteurs madame la ministre chers
collègues
l'amendement 177 vise à attirer
l'attention de la haute assemblée sur un
problème qui nous semble un problème
crucial et que visiblement personne a
pris à bras le corps comme vous le savez
les tribunaux et le conseil d'état
reconnaît ce defacto 1 droit à
l'instruction quelle que soit la
situation administrative des mineurs et
à ce titre il peut arriver que çà et là
et nous nous en réjouissons des jeunes
dépourvus de titre de séjour soit
scolarisé dans un établissement et puis
ce type r d études lycées lycées
professionnels etc
il y a là une bizarrerie de notre
législation qui fait qu'un jeune dans la
même situation peut être admis et nous
le souhaitons et le défendons dans un
lycée alors qu'il ne peut defacto
conclure un contrat d'apprentissage et
donc nous souhaiterions contenu de ce
qu'a dit à madame ferrat ce matin d'un
certain nombre de jeunes qui ont le goût
de l'apprentissage qui ont envie
d'apprendre et de filières où il y a des
propositions d'apprentissage et où il ya
et il y a aussi des débouchés
nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi parfois
ces jeunes sans papiers que nous
défendons dans notre groupe avec vigueur
peuvent aller au lycée pour ce qui
on dont le souhait est la volonté c'est
très bien en revanche pour ceux qui
souhaitent être apprenti c'est la
brouille au juridique et donc à cette
fin nous vous avons fait une proposition
qui permettrait pour un jeune qui trouve
enfin qu'un apprentissage de pouvoir
avoir des facto une carte d'étudiant
même si effectivement cela paraîtra
audacieux à certains je vois déjà ce
qu'on va me dire nous ne craignons
aucunement à quelconque a fait appel
d'air nous pensons simplement que ça
donnera une solution positive pour les
chefs d'entreprises qui cherchent des
apprentis pour ces jeunes qui ont envie
de faire de l'apprentissage et qui pour
certains avaient déjà pratiqué des
activités dans leur métier et pour tout
le monde et donc nous souhaiterions
vraiment que cette problématique soit
prise à bras le corps par les différents
ministères concernés
merci mais la mouche où je vais donc
demander l'avis de la commission sur cet
amendement 177 dans mon coeur alors
madame bouchaud aux termes de l'article
l 313 7 du code de l'entrée et du séjour
des étrangers
la carte de séjour temporaire étudiants
est accordé de droit aux étrangers
étudiants dans le supérieur
boursier du gouvernement français
scolarisés pendant trois ans dans un
établissement français à l'étranger ou
ressortissant d'un pays ayant signé un
accord de réciprocité
les apprentis mineurs ne sont pas
assimilables à cette catégorie c'est
bien ce que vous dites il faut rappeler
qu'ils ont signé un contrat de travail
c'est plutôt la délivrance de la carte
de séjour temporaire étudiants qui
donnent le droit à l'exercice d'une
activité professionnelle à titre
accessoire donc l'amendement renverse la
logique en prévoyant que l'exercice
d'une activité salariée dans le cadre
d'une formation en alternance abouti à
la délivrance de la carte de séjour
étudiant
cela ne nous paraît pas aujourd'hui
cohérent avec le dispositif tel qu'il
est
de plus nous pensons que
ce n'est pas le vous poser un vrai sujet
mais c'est sans doute pas ici et dans le
cadre de cette loi que nous pouvons le
régler l'intérêt bien sûr vous attirez
l'attention je crois que tout le monde
l'entend donc au nom de cela puisque
nous ne sont pas en capacité de répondre
ici dans le cas de la loi nous pourrions
vous demander le retrait merci madame le
rapporteur l'avis du gouvernement madame
le ministre
c'est quand même moi qui préside
oui je crois qu'effectivement le sujet
que vous évoquez est un sujet important
il est clair que même dans les lycées
professionnels
nous voyons beaucoup de jeunes par
exemple beaucoup de jeunes des mineurs
étrangers isolés qui se retrouvent dans
la situation de pouvoir suivre une
scolarité mais de ne pas pouvoir aller
en stage ou de ne pas pouvoir le faire
en alternance
donc il me semble que c'est un sujet
réel toutefois je n'ai pas le sentiment
que nous puissions leur régler ici dans
texte sur l'école donc je crois que nous
avons besoin d'y travailler avec le
ministère de l'intérieur
parce que effectivement pour beaucoup
d'enseignants pour beaucoup de
responsables de nos établissements
la situation de ces jeunes est
préoccupante mais actuellement je pense
qu'il vaudrait mieux que vous retiriez
le sujet et que nous irons travaillons
avec le ministère de l'intérieur
merci madame le ministre madame ne
bouchonne vous êtes sollicité à deux
reprises pour un retrait que décidé vous
madame la présidente
excusez moi d'avoir été trop vite
j'entends bien ce que nous dit madame la
rapporteure j'entends bien ce que dit
madame la ministre
et donc je conçois retirer cet
amendement
simplement j'aimerais vraiment qu'on
prenne ce problème à bras le corps et
pas que ce soit reporté aux calendes
grecques parce que je ne cite jamais le
département dont je suis originaire le
maine et loire mais je peux vous dire
que sur ce sujet le changement c'est pas
tout de suite et que avec le précédent
préfet sous le précédent gouvernement
sur ce dossier là on n'avançait plus
vite que maintenant et donc si je
pouvais à la fois faire avancer le débat
pour tous et dans l'intérêt général et
attirer l'attention de madame la
ministre qui pourra lorsqu'elle croisera
monsieur valls lui signaler
la situation d'un certain nombre de
jeunes j'aurais fait oeuvre utile pour
tout le monde je vous remercie
je retire merci chers collègues
l'article 39 est supprimée il le demeure
donc pas de vote selon l'article 39
après l'article 39-1 amendement 241
monsieur gendre l'homme la présidente
monsieur madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
notre préoccupation est évidemment que
les élèves quand ils doivent choisir et
leurs familles
elle est meilleure information sur les
débouchés de en fonction des filières
qu'ils auront choisi voilà pourquoi nous
souhaitons que des informations leur
soit donné que les établissements
d'enseignement scolaire rendre publics
des statistiques comportant des
indicateurs de réussite aux examens et
aux diplômes qu'ils délivrent de
poursuite d'études et d'insertion
professionnelle
nous souhaitons que les élèves ou
apprentis dispose en amont de leur
orientation de ces informations de
manière à faire leur choix en toute
connaissance de cause
merci monsieur gendre je vais donc
demander l'avis de la commission m le
rapporteur oui madame la présidente
alors d'abord un petit problème pardon
de rédaction parce qu à proprement
parler les établissements scolaires ne
délivre pas eux mêmes les diplômes sur
le fond la publication de données brutes
et on l'a souvent évoqué peut donner une
image biaisée des établissements parce
que ne prenant pas en compte les efforts
des équipes pédagogiques dans les
établissements difficiles pour justement
à la fois permettre à des enfants de
reprendre pied
et justement de mieux réussir
également elle permet de retrouver la
confiance des parents cela aboutirait à
une mise en concurrence sans aucun moyen
justement d'apporter un soutien et un
signe positif aux équipes en difficulté
ce classement peut être aussi anxiogène
pour des parents qui voudront
alors évitez absolument le mauvais
établissements je le mets entre
guillemets en d'autres termes je trouve
que ce type de classement pourrait avoir
des effets très délétère et donc avis
défavorable merci madame la rapporteure
l'avis du gouvernement madame la
ministre madame il est clair que pour
nous nous comprenons ce qui peut motiver
cette demande mais manifestement ce type
de statistiques
comme l'a dit madame la rapporteure
risque de biaiser l'opinion qu'on a des
établissements de surcroît on peut avoir
évidemment les statistiques sur les
résultats aux examens mais en matière
d'emploi le jeune n'est pas obligé de
rester directement demander un emploi
autour de l'établissement où ils se
trouvent par conséquent ce serait un
travail assez complexe et nous ne voyons
pas réellement ce que ça donnera de plus
par rapport à des statistiques plus
générale en termes d'accès à l'emploi
des jeunes
donc nous sommes défavorables merci
madame la ministre monsieur legendre
oui madame la présidente mme amah
ministre mes chers collègues il faut
regarder comment les choses se passent
actuellement sortent régulièrement dans
la presse des classements des
établissements et ils sont faits selon
des modalités aléatoire il donne des
classements les critères sur lesquels
ces classements ont été établis sont
souvent vagues et ne donne pas toutes
garanties
il me semble qu'il serait plus pertinent
que l'éducation nationale puisse donner
quelques indications et éventuellement
attirer l'attention sur le type
particulier des équipes enseignantes
disponible dans tel ou tel établissement
si l'éducation ne le fait pas c'est la
presse qui le fera vous ne pourrez
évidemment pas l'en empêcher
elle le fera souvent sur des critères
biaisé voilà pourquoi je préférerais que
ce que le service public de l'éducation
essaye lui même de fournir ces
comparaisons mais si ses collègues
je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement 241 présentée par monsieur
legendre qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
merci contre 6 abstentions
l'amendement 241 n'est pas adopté avant
l'article 40 un amendement de 29
rectifié qui n'est pas défendu
il tombe article 40
un amendement 328 présenté par notre
collègue madame gillot oui madame la
présidente madame la ministre les chers
collègues il s'agit d'ajouter au
deuxième alinéa avant lavables au début
de la première phrase au début de la
deuxième phrase pardon en cohérence avec
le projet éducatif territorial celui ci
propose parce que la création du conseil
écoles collèges est vraiment une avancée
majeure de cette loi et je pense que il
est important depuis ce qu'on vise à
favoriser les actions de coopération des
enseignements et des projets
pédagogiques communs entre l'école les
écoles et le collège il est pertinent
d'inscrire ce travail dans le cadre du
projet éducatif territorial qui est
délibérée avec l'avis des conseils
d'école donc ce conseil écoles collèges
me semble être cohérent il est cohérent
de l'introduire dans la dans le projet
éducatif territorial
merci madame gillot l'avis de la
commission râble madame merci madame le
ministre favorable même si je vais donc
mettre aux voix l'amendement 328
présenté par notre collègue madame
gillot deux avis favorables kippour
merci contre l'abstention l'amendement
328 est adopté je suis saisie de quatre
moments faisant l'objet d'une discussion
commune
le premier présenté par notre collègue
jean mais ce genre de 100 m3
pas présente à la main ministre mes
chers collègues nous proposons après les
mots coopération de rédiger à 6 la fin
de cette phrase au deuxième alinéa
deuxième phrase et des connaissances
pédagogiques communs visant à
l'acquisition par les élèves du socle
commun de connaissances et de
compétences prévues à l'article l 122 1
l'article tel qu'il est rédigé
actuellement donne au conseil
écoles collèges la capacité de proposer
des enseignements visant l'acquisition
du socle commun
or les enseignements relève du cadre
national des programmes et ne peuvent
procéder d'une initiative locale
par ailleurs le statut des personnels
enseignants
dans le premier le second degré suppose
la même distinction d enseignement voilà
pourquoi nous proposons cet amendement
merci messieurs les gendres la moment
129 et le 136 vous voulez c'est ce que
j'allais vous proposez là alors je
commence sur 129 l'article 40 créé des
conseils écoles collèges censé favoriser
la transition entre le cm2 et la 6e
souvent difficile pour les élèves on le
sait ces conseils ne nous paraissent pas
évident du tout à mettre en oeuvre sur
un même secteur un collège correspond à
plusieurs écoles primaires qui elles
peuvent avoir des caractéristiques en
font très différentes
la mise en place d'actions de
coopération et de projet pédagogique
commun n'ira donc pas de soi quoi qu'il
en soit ce qui nous pose réellement
problème c'est la possibilité prévue par
cet article de mettre en oeuvre des
enseignements communs entre ces deux
niveaux
nous ne sommes pas favorable à la
mutualisation ni d'enseignement ni
d'enseignants là encore il nous semble
difficile nous sommes difficiles à
mettre en oeuvre quelques cours quel
enseignant dans quel lieu dans quelle
salle de place pour réunir plus de
soixante élèves et surtout pour quel
objectif pédagogique
la création de ce conseil et les
objectifs qui lui sont assignés nous
paraissent donc plutôt du domaine
incantatoire je vais dire si ces projets
voient le jour nous ne voyons pas en
quoi ils permettront d'adopter des
réponses aux difficultés de transition
que peuvent rencontrer certains certains
élèves quand bien même il le pourrait
nous ne souhaitons surtout pas ouvrir la
voie à une fusion entre ces deux niveaux
de leurs enseignants pas plus que nous
ne souhaitons créer un cycle commun
entre ces deux niveaux
notre entendement surpris supprime donc
la mutualisation des enseignements qui
est un premier pas dans ce sens mais ne
s'oppose pas pour autant à l'idée de
tenter de mettre en place des projets
communs ça nous confirme ça nous
confirme quand même dans notre idée nous
avons défendu tout au long de cette
séance et précédemment en commission
c'est que quand mais nous aurions dû
prendre le temps de beaucoup plus de
recul sur l'examen de l'organisation des
cycles et des rythmes et je dis un mot
sur le 130 vraiment c'est un amendement
de coordination puisque vous savez nous
préférerions que nous avancions sur la
notion de culture commune plutôt que
d'un sac d'un socle commun
même réformée merci madame gonthier
maurin le 254 actifs y est madame
laborde la présidente la transition
entre l'école primaire et l'école
secondaire peut s'avérer difficile
lorsque les compétences de base n'ont
pas été acquises ou lorsqu'elles ont été
mal acquise un élève sur cinq rencontres
des difficultés à l'écrit en début de
sixième al ce titre il convient donc de
saluer plusieurs dispositions du projet
de loi qui permettront d'apporter un
remède à cette transition à brut
c'est le cas de l'article 23 dans sa
rédaction adoptée par d'autres
commission de la culture et de
l'éducation qui s'inscrit dans la loi
l'intention du gouffre qui inscrit
pardon dans la loi l'intention du
gouvernement de créer un cycle commun
réunissant le cm2 et la sixième c'est
également le cas de l'articulation
prévue entre les programmes scolaires et
les cycles d'enseignement
c'est enfin le cas de la mise en place
des conseils écoles collèges à l'article
ces derniers pourront proposer des
actions de coopération des enseignements
et des projets pédagogiques communs pour
faciliter l'acquisition du socle commun
le présent amendement vise à préciser
que ces actions doivent être surtout
proposé pendant le cycle court moyen
sixième je vous remercie
merci madame laborde madame
rapporteur on la commission sur cette
série d'amendements votre avis
l'amendement de monsieur legendre le
contrainte contrairement à ce que
prétend l'objet de l'amendement le code
de l'éducation permet aujourd'hui des
expérimentations pédagogiques locales y
compris les enseignements c'est inscrit
dans l'article l 420-1 issus du fameux
article 34 de la loi fillon de 2005 dont
notre votre collègue et notre collègue à
tous jean claude carle est un fervent
défenseur
il n'y a donc aucune raison de ne pas
contribuer à faciliter la transition de
cm2 6e grâce à des renseignements comme
un avis défavorable
madame gonthier maurin donc même objet
que le précédent même avis défavorable
même si j'ai entendu il n'est en aucun
cas question de fusion j'ai bien entendu
vous vos printemps un amendement de
coordination pour la main devant 130
défavorable et madame laborde précision
qui peut nous apparaître superflu dans
la mesure où la fonction même du conseil
écoles collèges et de faciliter la
transition
en outre le cycle court moyen 6e
n'existe pas en droit
donc on vous demanderai leur retrait
merci madame la rapporteure l'avis du
gouvernement madame le ministre sur
cette série d'amendements
effectivement je partage de la vie de
madame là le rapporteur parce que je
comprends bien la volonté exprimée dans
ces amendements qui est à la fois de
voir comme nous une continuité entre le
primaire et le collège et en même temps
de ne pas aller trop loin pour éviter
qu'il y ait en quelque sorte
mutualisation qu'on confonde les étapes
mais il me semble que le texte tel qu'il
est est parfaitement clair comme l'a
rappelé la madame le rapporteur on a la
possibilité de faire des
expérimentations
donc il me semble que ces amendements
n'apporte rien de particulier à notre
démarche commune
si madame la ministre je vais donc
mettre au voile madame laborde sur sur
le vôtre eux au moment où il viendra g
oui j'ai eu m envoie l'amendement 223
cas reçu deux avis défavorables qui est
pour
merci contre merci abstentions il n'est
pas adopté le 129 présenté par madame
gauthier maurane deux avis défavorables
les quais pour contre merci abstention
n'est pas adopté même votre pour le
centre ans même vote merci l'amendement
254 rectifié madame laborde vous avez la
parole merci excusez moi comme il était
en somme c'est que quand on commençait
le vote on n'avait plus le droit de
donner son avis j'étais un peu perdu
donc je voulais juste préciser que
c'était un amendement d'appel que j'ai
bien conscience que quand on écrit
notamment c'est pas très juridique
donc je le retirerais puisque j'ai eu
mes réponses je vous remercie merci
madame laborde
nous en arrivons à l'amendement 172
présenté par madame blue madame la
présidente madame la présidente de
commission le rapporteur madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre je me
permets de rappeler que nous avons fait
beaucoup d'amendements d'appel et on a
été extrêmement pragmatique depuis ce
matin donc je voulais attirer votre
attention et j'ai bien entendu ce qu'ont
dit nos amis effectivement pas d' usine
à gaz entre le primaire et la 6e pas
d'atteinte au statut nous voulions
simplement renforcé alinéa 2 après la
deuxième phrase quelque chose qui
néanmoins et on a bien entendu les
réserves permettraient d'atténuer le gap
la transition énorme qu'il y as entre le
primaire et la 6e et donc nous vous
proposons de pouvoir prévoir que dans la
limite de trois journées par année
scolaire des échanges de pratiques et
d'enseignants entre les établissements
peuvent peuvent être expérimenté sur la
base du volontariat et sur décision du
conseil
il nous semble dans la mesure où nous
nous sommes renseignés cela existe déjà
quasi systématiquement est assez
régulièrement
cela nous sembleraient on va dire de
nature à renforcer le volontarisme de
cette loi de simplement l'inscrire tél
elle ça nous semble être on va dire une
sécurisation de quelque chose auquel
nous tombe beaucoup sans froisser
personne ni d'un côté ni de l'autre je
vous remercie
merci madame boussioux je vais donc
demander l'avis de la commission madame
la rapporteure oui madame la pause les
échanges d'enseignants peuvent poser des
difficultés d'autres d'ordre statutaire
le conseil école collège n'est pas
compétent pour prendre de telles
décisions dont la commission a émis un
avis défavorable mais nous souhaitons
avoir la position du gouvernement
merci madame le rapporteur madame la
ministre pour le gouvernement
oui effectivement je crois que l'idée
qui est contenu dans cet amendement qui
propose des échanges de pratiques et
entre enseignants c'est quelque chose me
semble-t-il qui est intéressant mais
votre amendement est extrêmement précis
dans trois journées vraiment c'est
quelque chose de surcroît qui s'appuie
sur une décision du conseil qui n'est
pas possible
donc nous nous serions favorables à ce
que l'on puisse maintenir votre idée
mais avec une formulation qui seraient
différentes
nous pourrions par exemple vous proposer
de l'eusew d'amendé de la manière
suivante à l'alinéa 2 de kasserine
phrase ainsi rédigée
parmi ces propositions des échanges de
pratiques et d'enseignants entre les
établissements peuvent être expérimenté
sur la base du volontariat
donc c'est une formulation plus souple
qui est me semble-t-il reprend votre
idée sans les obstacles
est ce que vous seriez d'accord mais
l'ambition pour sous-amendé votre
volontiers donc je reprends cette
proposition qui nous est faite que je
salue donc nous proposons l'amendement
ainsi modifié merci monsieur gendre je
crois que même bouchon avait eu raison
mètres le point le doigt sur l'intérêt
de ces échanges et si la proposition de
formulation du ministre peut permettre
de régler ce problème je le voterai très
volontiers
merci monsieur les chambres de se manier
la présidente
là les dysfonctions ministre mes chers
collègues
ce fut un moment où cette précision
apportée par le gouvernement convient
groupe socialiste avec simplement une
précision que je souhaite qui sera fait
j'imagine sexy note ne portent pas
atteinte au statut des enseignants qui
sont concernés par ces échanges bien
entendu merci monsieur manier
madame gonthier maurin oui moi je sais
pas s'il faut mettre ça dans la loi mais
disons que nous n'échappons pas au débat
et au moins il fera peut-être avancer
les choses
moi je comprends l'idée du besoin de
coopération des changes de parcours plus
fluide entre ces deux différents niveaux
mais ce qui m'inquiète profondément
c'est que l'on engage par petits
morceaux sans avoir une réflexion
globale d'ensemble sur la pédagogie que
l'on doit dispenser à chaque niveau donc
je voterai contre si madame gauthier
morin madame la ministre je tient
effectivement à préciser que nous sommes
absolument attachés au respect du statut
des enseignants là-dessus il n'y a aucun
aucun doute simplement là en l'espèce il
s'agit bien d'expérience dans le cadre
de volontariat donc à mon sens là dessus
ce sont les enseignants qui peuvent
choisir ou pas de se lancer là-dedans et
par conséquent bon à la limite on peut
dire que ce dans le respect du statut
des enseignants mais sam à mon sens ça
va sans dire mais bon mais on peut le
mettre si vous savez vous reveniez on
peut le mettre dans le respect du statut
des enseignants ok mais a pas de souci
dans le respect de ses ministres c'est
un amendement qui est très important
mais qui ne rajoute rien et donc nous
allons accepter à ce qui existe déjà
l'article 34 qui fonctionne depuis des
années permet aux uns et aux autres de
s'organiser un certain nombre de
conditions déjà très précisément
analyser et heureusement car parmi les
plus belles réussites qu'on a en
éducation prioritaire c'est précisément
quand ce travail est déjà organisée sur
le terrain entre les écoles et les
collèges
nous étions d'ailleurs allé avec le
président de la république attrapé ça
avait été très relayée à l'époque voire
une très belle expérience de cette
nature donc ça ne pose aucun problème de
le réécrire ce sera simplement une
redondance
merci monsieur le ministre oui bien pour
la clarté pour la clarté je vais relire
je vais relire donc l'amendement 172
rectifié bis vous proposez bien madame
la ministre
l'excellent l'expression suivante parmi
ces propositions des échanges de
pratiques et d'enseigner entre les
établissements peuvent être expérimenté
sur la base du volontariat et sur
décision du conseil dans le respect du
statut des enseignants voilà pas conseil
d'accord d'accord alors parmi ces
propositions des échanges de pratiques
et d'enseignants entre les
établissements peuvent être expérimenté
sur la base du volontariat dans le
respect du statut des enseignants voilà
très bien vient écouter alors je vais
les mettre aux voix avec avis bien sûr
que sa maman sous-amendé par par le
gouvernement qui pour merci contre merci
abstentions l'amendement 172 rectifié
bis est adopté nous en venons au vote
sur l'article 40 il ya t'il une
initiative des explications de vote sur
cet article
je ne vois pas je mets aux voix qui est
pour voter l'article 40
merci contre l'abstention l'article 40
est adopté l'article 40 bis je mets aux
voileux 40 bis quai pour
merci contre l'abstention il est adopté
chine l'article 41 à la maman 224 qui
est présentée par me sur les jambes
la présidente mes chers collègues
la nouvelle rédaction de l'article 411 1
supprime la mention de la présence d'un
représentant de la commune ou de
l'établissement public de coopération
intercommunale lors des réunions avec
les parents d'élèves
quand on se réunit avec les parents
d'élèves souvent des questions qui
relèvent aussi d'une manière ou d'une
autre de la commune sont évoqués il nous
paraît donc utile car représentant de la
commune soit toujours présent et nous
voulons l'affirmé le réécrire clairement
dans le texte
si monsieur les gens madame le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission sur
le 224 à leurs lames en demande de
monsieur le gendre nous apparaît sans
objet car l'article 41 incorpore le
comité de parents dans le conseil
d'école dont il ne forme et de toute
façon qu'un démembrement
il n'y aura donc plus de réunions
séparées du comité de parents en
revanche la commune est toujours
représentée dans le conseil d'école donc
avis défavorable merci madame la
rapporteure l'avis du gouvernement mais
malvy merci mais voilà
merci monsieur jambes je suis saisi de
deux amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 225 monsieur
legendre
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
souhaitons préciser que au conseil
d'école
il ya au moins un tiers de représentants
élus de la commune ou de l'établissement
public de coopération intercommunale
compétent pour le fonctionnement de
l'école et parmi ceux-ci le maire ou le
président de l'établissement public de
coopération intercommunale sur les gens
mal à me faire à un amendement identique
vous présenter oui merci mais de la
présidente
effectivement cet amendement est
identique que 225 qui vient d'être
défendu par nos collègues du groupe ump
et je ne reviens pas sur le fond mais
pour notre part il vient compléter et
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire à de
nombreuses reprises tous les amendements
que nous avons déposés en faveur des
collectivités locales et des élus
une meilleure intégration des élus dans
le système éducatif et une meilleure
concertation surtout sur la mise en
oeuvre des réformes sont indispensables
elles bénéficieront directement aux
enfants et cet amendement le liant la
place des cellules dans les conseils
d'école
merci madame ferrat pour la commission
madame le rapporteur alhazen avis sur
les deux bien sûr au moins un titre donc
la composition du conseil d'école relève
du règlement article d 411 1 du code de
l'éducation
donc nous ne pouvons que soit posée un
avis défavorable soit vous demander de
les retirer puisque ce n'est pas un
l'objet ici
merci même le rapporteur l'avis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre mais
ma vie merci messieurs les jambes
la présidente communiste mes chers
collègues je retirerais volontiers cet
amendement mais je crois qu'il est quand
même utile à l'occasion de ces débats
que dans la ce qui sera indiqué sur les
travaux que nous avons ici on confirme
bien la nécessité que les représentants
des communes soit partie prenante dans
cette affaire et de manière à ce qu'on
le retrouve dans le règlement merci
messieurs l'usma la mère a voulu retirer
également je vous remercie
nous en arrivons au vote sur l'article
41 y at il une demande de parole je n'en
vois pas je vais donc on voit l'article
41 kg et pour merci contre abstentions
l'article 41 et adopté l'article 42 à
l'amendement 417 mais c'est luminis vous
le présenter oui c'est un amendement de
précisions le projet d'article modifie
et c'est une bonne chose la composition
du conseil d'administration des
établissements publics locaux
d'enseignement souhaitant c'était notre
intention on en parle depuis le début
des débats renforcer la place des
collectivités locales de rattachement de
l'établissement public local
d'enseignement d'éducation afin de
faciliter la présence des représentants
des collectivités la commission a choisi
d'adopter un amendement qui précise que
l'un des représentants au plus de la
collectivité de rattachement peut-être
une personnalité qualifiée désignée par
le président de la collectivité le
gouvernement partage la préoccupation de
la commission et souhaite que la
présence des représentants de la
collectivité de rattachement puisse être
facilité certaines collectivités pensons
que ces régionaux au lycée ayant de
nombreuses pme qui leur sont rattachés
cependant la rédaction retenue par la
commission pourrait conduire à ce que
l'unique représentant de la collectivité
de rattachement ne soit pas un élu c'est
le cas des epn n'ayant que 24 membres
avec la présence d'un opci en outre le
terme retenu par la commission de
personnalités qualifiées et réservé à
une autre catégorie des membres du
conseil d'administration
c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous proposer un amendement
rédactionnelle qui permet de désigner un
représentant non membres de l'assemblée
ça veut dire donc quand même engageant
la collectivité et donc agent
territorial dans le seul cas où le
nombre de représentants soit au moins 2
2 et donc alinéa 5 rédigé ainsi cet
alinéa lorsque les représentants d'une
même collectivité territoriale sont au
nombre de deux l'un d'entre eux peut ne
pas être membre de l'assemblée
délibérante
merci monsieur le ministre l'avis de la
commission sur cet amendement du
gouvernement avis favorable avoir pu
vous remercie madame le rapporteur je
vais donc mettre aux voix l'amendement
417 à montceau légende
oui je voulais être sûr de bien
comprendre monsieur le ministre je
comprends tout à fait que dans le cas
d'une très grande ville avec de très
nombreuses écoles il soit difficile
d'avoir un membre de l'assemblée
délibérante va deux membres qu'ils
puissent se rendre dans tous les
conseils et cas si on y met un peu de
souplesse
ça ne pose pas de problème je le
comprends ça prenne pratique mais je
quand je pense que ceci ne peut être
fait que quand il est constaté que tous
les membres du conseil municipal du
conseil communautaire sont au moins déjà
affecté à un conseil d'école ça vient
après sinon ça pourrait être aussi une
façon pour une majorité municipale
quelle qu'elle soit de ne jamais donner
de place à sa minorité est ainsi
d'envoyer un non élu alors que des élus
ne seraient pas utilisés à siéger dans
une dans un concert une dans un conseil
d'école
je voudrais nous prémunir de cette
déviation
merci monsieur gendre mais ce ministre
je suis précision mais on parle des yeux
pe et pas des conseils d'école donc des
établissements publics les écoles n'en
sont pas et donc ça concerne pas ce
monsieur le ministre je vais donc mettre
aux voix l'amendement 417 du
gouvernement qui avait un avis favorable
de la commission qui est pour
merci
contre abstentions un amendement 417 et
adopté l'amendement 264 rectifiée
présentée par madame laborde la
présidente merci cet amendement vise
simplement un reporter la discussion sur
la représentation de la métropole au
sein du conseil d'administration des
établissements publics locaux
d'enseignement lors des projets de lois
de décentralisation merci madame laborde
l'avis de la commission
oui madame la présidente ligne
d'anticipation du texte métropole
puisque l'article 42 vise un article qui
existe depuis 2010 dans le code général
des collectivités territoriales et nice
possède déjà ce statut dont nous ne
sommes pas en anticipation
donc je vous demander le retrait parce
que la merci madame le rapporteur l'avis
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie madame laborde vous êtes
sollicité deux fois pour un retrait je
suis obligé de dire oui maintenant comme
il ya déjà un exemple non comme il ya
déjà un exemple
et puis ça va mieux en le disant et au
moins j'ai une explication claire je
vous remercie
on estime le bol en venant au vote sur
l'article 42 il n'y a pas de demande de
parole je mets aux voix l'article 42 qui
est pour
merci contre l'abstention l'article 42
adopté même vote pour l'article 43
mes chers collègues même vote même votre
merci l'article 44 même vote
alors j'aime et où voir l'article 44
vous voulez vous exprimer sur le 40 e
oui je vous en prie allez-y non non ce
pas trop tard quand même chez insiste
sur le 44 parce que c'est une question
qui me tient à coeur puisque cet article
redonne vie au greta organismes publics
de formation continue des adultes de
l'éducation nationale que la majorité
précédente avait supprimé au détour
d'une de ces loi de simplification du
droit pour les transformer en gip mon
groupe avait alors pointé les
difficultés que cela poserait notamment
pour les personnels et vous semblez
monsieur le ministre à lire l'étude
d'impact du projet de loi vous orienter
vers une sorte d'entre deux pour
l'avenir articulé greta egypte via agip
académique si j'ai bien compris le
problème des greta qui doivent
s'autofinancer est exacerbée par les
appels d'offres et le positionnement en
termes de concurrence avec les cfppa par
exemple qui dépendent eux du ministère
de l'agriculture
l'idée de faire émerger une structure
régionale académique se positionnant
comme un interlocuteur unique face aux
régions est intéressante
cependant la forme d'un établissement
public régional serait préférable à
celle d'egypte pourquoi d'abord parce
que l'egypte peuvent être composé
d'établissements publics mais aussi
privés de plus l'egypte peuvent recruter
des personnels de droit privé dans la
structure j -p
il n'y a pas de représentants des
personnels et son principe et sont
seulement présents les représentants des
structures qui composent le gip comme lé
directeur du greta
c'est à dire le chef de l'établissement
support du greta ou son représentant
mais pas les formateurs ainsi si l'idée
d'une mise en synergies notamment pour
les appels d'offres évitant que les
centres publics ne se positionnent ne se
positionnent en concurrence nous pensons
que la structure juridique pardon doit
être déterminée au regard des critères
qui viennent d'être évoqués
merci madame emond comptiez morin
j'aimerais voir l'article 44 qui est
pour
merci contre
abstention l'article 44 et adopté après
l'article 44 je suis saisi de trois
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 131 madame
gonthier-maurin madame assassines merci
madame la présidente
cet amendement a pour objet d'abroger
les dispositions qui tendent à garantir
la parité de financement entre les
écoles élémentaires publiques et privées
sous contrat d'association lorsqu'elles
accueillent des élèves scolarisés hors
de leur commune de résidence
cette proposition que nous avons déjà
formulées par le dépôt d'une proposition
de loi trouve écho chez une partie enfin
devrais trouver écho chez une partie de
nos collègues socialistes puisque 40
députés de leur groupe avait envisagé de
défendre un amendement similaire
similaire à l'assemblée nationale mais
l'on l'on retiré alors cette question ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui
elle se pose depuis cette adoption
malheureuse d'un amendement de notre
ancien collègue michel charasse destinée
en fait à régler rappelons-nous une
situation locale devenue donc l'article
89 de la loi numéro 2004 qui réunit son
hub et 13 13 août 2004 puis la loi carle
en 2009
pour notre part nos points d'opposition
n'ont pas varié et les courriers divers
notamment de maires de communes rurales
mais également de communes franciliennes
par exemple de mère de mon département
la seine saint denis montre que la
question est toujours d'actualité
ce qui est certain c'est que cette loi a
maintenu une véritable différence de
traitement entre l'école publique et
l'école privée au détriment de la
première je rappelle en effet que le
financement d'un enfant scolarisé dans
l'école publique d'une autre commune que
celle de résidence et soumis à l'accord
préalable du maire
or cet accord n'est pas nécessaire
pour l'enseignement privé donc cela
conduit à des situations que je serai
qualifiée d'ubuesque encore dénoncé par
la rff ou des communes sans pouvoir
connaître le choix des familles
découvrent la facture des établissements
privés par la poste
ces dépenses pèsent donc sur le budget
sur les budgets des communes budget dont
nous savons toutes et tous qui vont être
de plus en plus contraints de plus ce
financement pénalise les efforts des
communes pour maintenir un service
public de l'éducation
et l'on sait couverture et fermetures de
classes peuvent se jouer à chaque
rentrée et pour quelques unités
trop de petites communes rurales voile
aux écoles fermées faute de moyens pour
qu'on me permette l'affectation de leurs
maigres ressources à des écoles privées
l'argent public doit donc
prioritairement permettent de financer
sur tout le territoire des écoles
publiques qui elles ne choisissent pas
leurs élèves
mais accueille gratuitement tous les
enfants de la république
de plus la loi carle et son décret
d'application signés à quelques jours du
changement de majorité de prendre en
compte la capacité d'accueil du
regroupement pédagogique intercommunal
que si les communes qui en sont membres
ont transféré la compétence scolaire à 1
2 pci ce que nous avions déjà dénoncé et
donc avec cet amendement nous proposons
de revenir à la situation qui prévalait
avant l'adoption de ce malheureux
article 89
merci madame la présidente à ça si
l'amendement 286 rectifie bis madame
laborde
merci madame la présidente donc bien sûr
ça va dans le même sens je vais
reprendre mois à la loi du 28 octobre
2009 puisque avant je n'étais pas là sur
le financement des écoles privées donc
plus connu sous le nom de loi carle qui
rend donc obligatoire la participation
financière de la commune de résidence
lorsque celle ci ne dispose pas des
capacités d'accueil nécessaires à la
scolarisation des élèves concernés
dans son ou ses écoles publiques ce qui
était alors membre de la haute assemblée
se souviennent combien l'examen de ce
texte avait passionné le sénat et les
sénateurs et les débats avaient été une
fois de plus de très bon niveau
c'est ainsi que nous avions soulevé la
question des regroupements pédagogiques
intercommunaux rpi liée à une autre
problématique plus globale celle de la
capacité d'accueil en effet de
nombreuses communes appartiennent à rpi
concentré ou dispersée et créer soit sur
l'initiative des communes elle même soit
de manière obligatoire conformément à
l'article l 212 2 du code de l'éducation
soit du fait du ministère de l'éducation
nationale qui impose fréquemment commune
de constituèrent pays sous peine de
suppressions de classes ou de fermetures
d'écoles c'est dans ces conditions que
le sénat avait alors adopté une large
majorité un amendement de notre collègue
pierre-yves collombat que je reprends
donc aujourd'hui amendement qui tendait
à apprécier la capacité d'accueil d'une
commune appartenant à air pays à
l'échelle de celui ci afin de sécuriser
la mise en place de ce dispositif au
regard de la diversité de statut dr pays
un sous-amendement présenté par notre
ancien collègue michel charasse avait
également été adoptées afin de préciser
qu'un décret fixerait les conditions de
prise en compte des rpi ce décret
d'application était pris le 9 novembre
2010 mais ils ne reflètent pas la
volonté du législateur et aboutit à
exclure du dip ou du dispositif
la moitié des airs pays puisqu'il
prévoit que la capacité d'accueil est
appréciée uniquement sur le territoire
de la commune de résidence de l'élève et
non pas par rapport à l'ensemble des
écoles du rpi
dès lors que celui-ci n'est pas adossé à
un opci en charge de la compétence
scolaire ce sont donc environ 2000 rpi
qui sont exclus pardon
ainsi une commune manders pays dont
l'école intercommunale est situé sur une
autre commune du périmètre sera obligés
de contribuer au financement de
l'enseignement privé puisque sa capacité
d'accueil sera appréciée sur son seul
territoire
le décret a eu pour conséquence de
pénaliser les petites communes qui n'ont
pas choisi de se regrouper en rpi et qui
ne sont pas membres d'un epci
l'objet de cet amendement est d'étendre
l'origine de la loi cale non seulement
au rpi à dos et un opci mais aussi à une
entente au sens du code général des
collectivités territoriales
c'est à dire à nantes formes souples
d'associations nécessitant simplement
des délibérations concordantes des
conseils municipaux de nombreuses
communes sont du fait de ce décret dans
une situation d'inégalité par rapport à
la loi
l'objet de cet amendement est d'y
remédier et de permettre ainsi de
dépassionner le débat sur la loi carle
en apportant des réponses concrètes et
efficaces sur le terrain
autant de solutions satisfaisantes pour
les familles et pour les collectivités
locales dans le respect du principe de
laïcité je m'excuse d'avoir été un peu
long mais là ça valait la peine
très bien madame laborde le 132e madame
gauthier morin malama ça si oui comme je
pense que malheureusement nous ne
réussirons pas vous convaincre de la
nécessité d'abroger la loi carle voilà
faut jamais douté de rien je sais bien
mais bon soyons lucides
soyons lucides donc je suis lucide et
donc je souhaiterais que le gouvernement
remette donc dans ces conditions un
rapport qui évalue l'impact des disques
de ces dispositions et notamment en
raison du décret pris par votre
prédécesseur monsieur ministre qui a
aggravé les choses
j'imagine de pas être les seuls la seule
donc je les dis à être saisie de
courriers de mer assailli par
l'enseignement privé notamment cap
solide qui en forment la composante
principale est d'avoir été de
reconnaître le désarroi je ne pas pas
jugement je fais un constat simplement
je ne me permettrais pas madame nous
souhaitons et j'insiste connaissant le
sort qui est généralement aux réserves
et aux rapports qu'il soit quand même
remis aux commissions compétentes du
sénat et de l'assemblée nationale avant
le 31 décembre 2013 et donne lieu
également à un débat en séance publique
merci madame la présidente à ça si je
vais donc demander l'avis de notre
rapporteur sur ces trois amendements
alors sur le premier amendement
bon je ne vais pas vous décevoir bien
sûr vous dit vous avez peu d'espoir
donc c'est vrai
nous n'allons pas émettre un avis
favorable à cette demande de suppression
pure et simple parce que donc justement
je vous renvoie à votre amendement qui
demande bien évidemment la réalisation
d'un bilan pour qu'on se prononce en
toute connaissance de cause et bien
évidemment sur votre amendement 132 je
donnerai un avis favorable
moyennant deux modifications qui avait
été prévu au moment de la commission et
qu'on a mis sur l'autre amendement sert
la date d'accord et la dernière phrase
vous savez donne une séance publique
parce qu'on a aussi le problème de
pouvoir on ça ne peut pas admis dans la
loi d'accord ainsi ça donc moyennant ces
deux avis favorables pour le
l'amendement 286 rectifié de madame
laborde
bien évidemment on le sait il y a eu un
grand débat ici au sénat lors de la loi
carle et la difficulté que vos pointes
et vient du fait que le décret en
conseil d'état d'application de la loi
carle prend en compte les capacités
d'accueil des rpi uniquement lorsqu'ils
sont adossées à une pci
or c'est vrai ce n'est pas le cas d'un
grand nombre de rpi donc cette lecture
peut nous faire penser que le décret n'a
pas respecté la volonté du sénat à
l'origine et c'est sans doute pour cela
que la commission a émis un avis
favorable
merci un avis favorable sur les 286
rectifier c'est ça madame un rapporteur
madame le rapporteur votre avis sur
l'amendement présenté par la manade
laborde
j'ai bien ri favorable la commission
avait émis un avis favorable merci très
bien monsieur le ministre
bien je suis sur le premier amendement
l'avis de la commission donc un amant un
avis défavorable
je tiens à dire quand même que si nous
ne le faisions pas nous risquerions
d'ouvrir à nouveau des périodes
d'incertitude juridique et je tiens à
dire aussi que le ministère n'a été
saisi jusque-là d'aucune d'aucun
contentieux concernant l'application de
la loi même si souvent politiquement
j'entends les uns et les autres
c'est ce qui me fait penser que pour
qu'il y ait clarification je suis aussi
favorable à l'amendement concernant donc
votre deuxième amendement concernant
l'étude et le rapport car il ya là
beaucoup d'équivoques par contre j'ai un
désaccord avec la commission sur
l'amendement de madame laborde pour la
raison que même si cette situation n'est
pas satisfaisante
il se fait que aujourd'hui l'avis rendu
par la section l'intérieur du conseil
d'état en 2010 a rappelé que la loi du
28 octobre 2009 a entendu garantir la
parité de financement entre les écoles
élémentaires publiques et privées sous
contrat d'association et le gouvernement
était alors prévu de tenues pardon de
prévoir que les capacités d'accueil du
regroupement pédagogique intercommunal
ne puisse être opposé par le maire que
si ce rpi est organisée dans le cadre
d'un établissement public de coopération
intercommunale
en conséquence et pour des raisons
juridiques le gouvernement ne peut être
que défavorable à cet amendement car il
constituerait en fait une rupture
d'égalité entre les deux articles
relatifs l'un au public l'autre au privé
est donc d'accord sur l'amendement 1
concernant le rapport est défavorable
sur deux autres amendements
merci monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente de la commission
entendu tout à fait d'accord avec cette
succession de propositions qui vont dans
le bon sens sur votre proposition de
demandes de rapports qui ne pourra que
donner les bases d'une réflexion et
d'arbitrage venir je rappelle quand même
qu'ici au sénat nous avons une
commission qui étudie l'application des
lois que ça c'est un bel exercice et que
ce rapport sera immédiatement mis dans
les mains de monsieur assouline
président de cette commission afin que
le sujet puisse être traité par les
membres de cette commission qui ont
l'habitude de nous donner à voir les
conséquences d'arbitrage passé si madame
la présidente de la commission monsieur
assouline g président à celui dont je
voudrais bon aussi si ma commission il
ya une demande pour faire ça ce sera
volontiers d'ailleurs j'ai on l'avait
dit en commission que ce serait ce que
l'on ferait donc cet amendement
demandant un rapport au gouvernement
moi je veux juste vous dire que dans
quelques semaines je vais remettre un
rapport de bilan annuel de contrôler
l'application des lois et une des choses
que que je fais remarquer c'est que à
chaque fois qu'on fait la loi en demande
des rapports oui et que je constate que
sur l'année qui s'écoulait c'est à peu
près ce qui s'est passé depuis à bitam
aeternam qui a pas 5% des rapports vous
un manteau qui arrivent malgré les
engagements votée dans la loi
donc bien sûr qu'on va les inciter à
réduire cette ce pourcentage mais
peut-être qu'il faudrait que le
législateur arrête à chaque fois qu'il
ya un sujet qui ne peut pas être intégré
à demander des rapports à la place parce
que la meilleure façon de crédibiliser
la loi c'est de faire qu'elles soient
pas trop verbeuse est trop sans
lendemain voilà il me suit le président
assouline mais se manier
madame la présidente monsieur michel
collègues sur ces amendements
effectivement je rappelle simplement
mais la présidente a précisé qu'il la
demande avait été faite j'avais présenté
déjà depuis quelques mois une demande de
contrôle de l'application de cette loi
dite dit luc carl cas évoqué notre
collègue tout à l'heure je crois
comprendre que maintenant sept ans va
accéder à cette demande donc moyennant
ces précisions que nous a dit monsieur
le ministre
suite à l'avis de même le rapporteur le
groupe socialiste ne votera pas
l'amendement présenté par madame laborde
de 286 rectifié bis la suite à ces à ces
précisions et votera par contre
l'amendement nuire 132 qui demande un
rapport du groupe communiste merci
monsieur maniema damas
merci madame la présidente madame
monsieur le ministre la ministre mes
chers collègues je voudrais pour une
fois n'est pas coutume aller dans le
sens des propos de monsieur assouline
pour dire qu'effectivement il ya je suis
parlementaire depuis peu de temps
effectivement on demande beaucoup par
voie d'amendement beaucoup de rapports
sur des points qui me semble être
particulier je crois que la sagesse
voudrait peut-être qu on les rassemble
je regrette donc d'autant plus que
l'amendement présenté par monsieur
legendre et été rejeté qui demandait un
rapport général sur l'application de
cette loi
juste avant le débat d'orientation
budgétaire et devant la présentation de
la loi de finances il aurait été utile à
ce moment-là de traiter l'ensemble de
ces pros de ces problèmes dans un seul
et unique rapport merci merci madame
frimas monsieur le ministre
oui je voulais remercier
madame assassiné son groupe d'avoir eu
cette bonne idée du rapport
non pas pour contredire le sénateur
assouline pour qui j'ai pour qui j'ai
une très grande considération mais parce
qu'il me semble quand même que sur le
sujet que nous traitons avec les plus de
deux millions d'enfants qui sont
concernés je vous rappelle que les
effectifs du public augmente
contrairement à une légende que
j'entends ceux du privé baisse dans
notre pays
je crois qu'il est sensé de bien se
documenter sur ce sujet avant de prendre
des résolutions qui créerait beaucoup
plus de difficultés on les a connus
d'ailleurs par le passé qu'on ne croit
en résoudre avec les bonnes intentions
donc nous liront avec trait avec une
très grand intérêt le rapport qui sera
commis sur cette question merci monsieur
le ministre très bien plus personne ne
demande la parole je vais donc mettre
aux voix
mes chers collègues je vais mettre voit
le 131 qui était présenté par madame
assassi qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour merci contre
merci abstentions merci l'amendement 131
n'est pas adopté l'amendement 286
rectifiée présentée par madame d'abord à
vous voulez vous exprimer mais même
là-bas c'est sur votre amendement alors
allez-y
merci beaucoup juste pour dire donc j'ai
bien entendu les avis favorables et
défavorables et que donc c'est un
rendement risque de ne pas être votée je
ne le retire rep ah vous comprenez que
j'ai des convictions
c'est normal et qui sont connus ça tombe
bien aujourd'hui voilà et je voulais
simplement dire que nous avons eu
l'occasion de discuter comme le
rappelait
damas à 6 ou madame gentiment hein à
l'assemblée il ya eu des discussions sur
l'abrogation ou non de la loi car il
n'est pas là mais je peux en parler
puisque je lui en ai parlé et on sait
que l'abrogation pure et simple ça
pourrait faire pire que donc c'est vrai
que cet amendement permettait une petite
évolution
donc nous ne manquerons pas de
travailler pour trouver une loi qui
puisse remplacer et permettre
l'abrogation de la loi carle je vous
remercie
merci madame laborde donc je mets votre
amendement aux voix un avis favorable de
la commission est défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour madame laborde
d'accord avec vous même très bien qui
est contre merci abstentions merci
l'amendement 286 rectifié bis n'est pas
adopté l'amendement 132 rectifié de
madame à ça si je rappelle que nous
avons nous avons rajouté pas nous avons
rectifié la date donc ses 31 décembre
2014 et que nous avons supprimé la
mention il donne lieu à un débat en
séance publique vous êtes d'accord avec
ça si les rectifier comme ça très bien
où je le mets aux voix deux avis
favorables qui est pour merci contre des
l'unanimité merci
nous arrivons à l'article 45 y at il une
demande de parole sur l'article 45
je n'en vois pas je mets aux voix
l'article 45 qui est pour merci contre
abstentions l'article 45 et adopté
l'article 45 bis je suis saisi de deux
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 418 que je vous
demande de présenter monsieur ministre
beaucoup de plaisir madame la présidente
la commission dans sa sagesse que nous
constatons amendement après amendement
avait souhaité introduire un article sur
l' architecture scolaire dans notre
projet de loi ça n'a l'air de rien c'est
très important
cet article précisé que dans tous les
établissements les parents d'élèves
doivent disposer d'un espace à leurs
usages
c'est un point très important pour
permettre aux parents de s'impliquer
dans la scolarité de leurs enfants
et cette implication nous l'avons dit
d'ailleurs dès le début des discussions
est essentiel pour la réussite des
élèves les parents sont des acteurs que
nous devons associer pleinement la
scolarité de leurs enfants
c'est souvent une des conditions de la
réussite des enfants
je suis donc très favorable à l'ajout
proposé par madame la rapporteure nous
souhaitons simplement précisé la
rédaction de cet ajout est en faire
valoir l'objectif cet espace dans les
établissements scolaires qui doit
permettre de favoriser les rencontres
individuelles ou collectives avec les
parents d'élèves et leurs représentants
et donc nous précisions l'objectif les
rencontres individuelles ou collectives
de cet espace qui sans ça restait
suspendue en l'air
merci monsieur le ministre l'avis de la
commission madame la rapporteur sur
l'amendement du gouvernement
ah oui c'est une fille qui ont connu une
pardon oui vous avez raison mais
l'aiglon d'un merci madame président non
mais c'est parce que j'allais complété
effectivement
l'amendement présenté par monsieur le
ministre je viendrai je viens tout
simplement demandé la possibilité
d'élargir l'utilisation de cette de cet
espace aux professionnels de santé et
professionnels sociaux car bon nombre
d'entre eux ne disposent d'aucun endroit
leur permettant de recevoir les familles
de s'entretenir avec les familles et
donc de les impliquer dans le suivi de
leurs enfants
cette utilisation donc par ses
personnels relève aussi d'une démarche
d'application rapide et peu coûteuse et
de plus cet espace hors al'avantage
d'être connus et reconnus par les
parents et facile d'accès et non
stigmatisant
voilà merci merci madame blondin bien
maintenant c'est quand même le rapporte
madame gonthier-maurin vous vouliez
exprimer
une explication de vote oui après donc
madame madame le rapporteur votre avis
d'abord bien madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre la rédaction que
vous nous proposez dans la lecture que
nous en faisons oriente fortement
l'utilisation des espaces qui pourrait
servir uniquement aux rencontres entre
les enseignants et les parents
la commission souhaitait laisser la
possibilité aux parents de se rencontrer
entre eux même en l'absence
d'enseignants
si l'on veut faire venir des familles
très éloignées de l'école il faut
qu'elle se sente à l'aise et nous savons
que la difficulté pour les faire venir
elle assimile cela à une espèce de
convocation et c'est comme cela que nous
avons des difficultés
donc on le sait dans un premier temps la
présence d'un membre de l'équipe
éducative peut être un frein à leur
venue c'est pour cela que la commission
avait émis un avis défavorable pour
celui excusez moi pour celui de madame
blonde incarne 5 bis donc tel qu'il est
rectifié avis favorable nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat mais nous
reviendrons plus largement dans nos
traditions de 19h sur l'examen de ce
projet de loi pour la refondation de
l'école de la république bonne soirée à
tous
à quoi ressemble les prisons russes qui
s'y entassent entre criminels victime
d'une illustration corrompus ou encore
opposants politiques
à quoi ressemble les prisons de poutine
et bien c'est le documentaire de la
semaine sur public sénat avec un débat
sur le président russe et sa façon très
particulière d'exercer le pouvoir
le débat présenté par benoît duquesne
dimanche à 10h sur public sénat bonjour
à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure de
parlement hebdo 45 minutes de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
avec mme moracchini bonjour jean michael
et bonjour à tous et dans l'actualité
cette semaine au ce que savait
exactement le gouvernement du compte en
suisse de jérôme cahuzac
c'est précisément ce que tentent
d'établir la commission d' enquête
parlementaire qui a commencé ses travaux
cette semaine
premier à être auditionné les
journalistes de médiapart
inutile d'embauché 60000 enseignants il
vaudrait mieux réorganiser le système
c'est le réquisitoire sévère de la cour
des comptes qui publie un rapport sur le
monde enseignant rapport choc en plein
débat sur la refondation de l'école et
puis françois hollande en allemagne pour
les 150 ans du parti social démocrate
il a loué les réformes engagées à
l'époque par gerhard schröder une
proximité politique qui a du mal à
passer du côté du parti socialiste
français avec nous pour commenter cette
actualité de la semaine françois lamy
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
ministre délégué à la ville côté de
cécile duflot
vous avez été député socialiste de
l'essonne pendant 15 ans avant de
rejoindre le gouvernement et oui 15 ans
alors évidemment vos anciens collègues
députés vous connaissent bien et valérie
brochard est allé tendre son micro comme
chaque semaine aux quatre colonnes pour
recueillir quelques avis c'est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement intelligent
voilà et d'assez opiniâtre c'est une
qualité en politique je suis en phase
totalement avec l'osq et aujourd'hui la
politique qu'il mène tant politiquement
que dans sa manière d'être
parce que la politique de la ville c'est
un savoir faire mais je peux vous en
parler en connaissance de cause c'est
aussi un savoir être
si je pouvais me permettre modestement
de lui donner un conseil
ça serait d'essayer de devenir un homme
du réel qui visitent bien l'assemblée je
crois que sa fonction finit bientôt ce
pas une bonne nouvelle ça commençait
bien ça parle de remaniement voilà
est-ce que ce que vous sentez sur un
siège éjectable c'est un petit peu de
moi je suis pas c'est pas quelque chose
c'est pas quelque chose que j'ai dans là
il y aura un remaniement un jour toute
façon on ne compte devient ministre
parce que par dépend d'un certain nombre
de circonstances qui sont qui sont
réunis mais c'est pas c'est pas un
métier vie donc oui un jour je ne serai
plus ministre mais c'est pour moi c'est
pas c'est pas une question donc pour moi
le problème c'est qu'on m'a le président
de la république m'a confié une mission
c'est d'essayer de la mener à bien on
trouve c'est de faire la réforme de la
politique de la ville je suis en train
de l'amener à et puis après j'ai eu une
vie avant j'aurais une vie après vous
êtes un des ministres discret du
gouvernement on peut dire ça comme ça à
ce que pensait que c'était plutôt un
gage de durée ou bien c'est à dire qu'il
faut se montrer plus non mais enfin je
moi de là encore je n'organise pas ma
vie médiatique en fonction du fait que
je pourrais rester ou partir c'est pas
c'est pas le sujet la ministre alors ça
nous peut-être bon mais en tout cas moi
je sais discrétion est dû à quoi
ali l'ugtt d'abord vous fait que les les
banlieues en difficultés on en parle
quand il les difficultés des violences
urbaines dans ce cas des faits de
délinquance donc là c'est plutôt du rôle
du ministre de l'intérieur mais celui
qui travaille qui répare qui reconstruit
celui là on n'y a pas le voir tous les
jours
bon et puis et puis deuxièmement je
crois qu'effectivement on n'est pas
obligé pour être efficace de d'avoir un
avis sur tout sur tous les sujets qu'on
connaît pas et donc voila moi je réponds
à toutes les invitations
et je m'efforce effectivement plutôt de
faire mon travail sérieusement qu'il
suppose quand même un gros travail que
de coordination et de nos relations avec
entre autres le monde associatif et les
élus amis vous êtes aussi ce qu'on peut
dire nous briest historique ça oui on
peut le dire on peut le dire martine
aubry aujourd'hui n'est que l'on
travaille parce que sa mise en examen
concernant une affaire d'amiante a été
levée est ce que vous estimez que sa
voix manque en ce moment on dit qu'on a
besoin de poids lourds dans la majorité
c'est elle et elle n'était pas entraver
politiquement par pas cette mise en
examen c'est pas ça qui séparent sa mise
en examen qui a fait que pour l'instant
la banque temps libre en tout cas oui
mais c'est pas c'est pas le sujet elle a
été première secrétaire du parti
socialiste pendant pendant trois heures
et demie elle a oeuvré à la réussite de
la gauche à mon avis de manière positive
elle a été aussi de candidate aux
primaires et surtout tout
particulièrement au deuxième tour donc
j'estime nécessaire pour l'instant de
badges à être utile
elle veut aider le gouvernement là
plusieurs façons de le faire
voilà la solution
oui tout à fait c'est pas inutile quand
quant à la une critique à faire vous
avez deux méthodes soit vous vous allez
voir les micros est assez critique
devient public et ça devient peut-être
un couac ça devient une difficulté saab
a besoin de cohérence
soit qu'elle fait c'est qu'elle prend
son téléphone et qu'elle appelle le
ministre concerné pour lui dire qu'elle
n'est pas d'accord allez on commence la
semaine avec la sphère cahuzac encore
l'opposition avait demandé une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire sur
la sphère cahuzac elle l'a eue première
audition en ce mardi inauguré par ce
sens qu'il affaire ne serait peut-être
pas sorti les journalistes de médiapart
ainsi que l'ancien adversaire de jérôme
cahuzac dans le lot-et-garonne audition
résumé signé par rabhi cas c'est par ces
deux hommes que le scandale est arrivé
fabrice arfi journaliste à mediapart et
edwy plenel fondateur du site
d'information sont au centre de
l'enquêté parlementaire sur la sphère
cahuzac selon fabrice arfi le
gouvernement pouvait difficilement
ignorer le compte en suisse de jérôme
cahuzac le 21 décembre
je crois que les pouvoirs publics les
administrations l'état au delà de ce qui
peut être se savait connaissez en détail
la sphère cahuzac
le fondateur de mediapart n'a pas changé
de discours une fois de plus
edwy plenel réitère ses accusations
contre le gouvernement et plus
particulièrement envers pierre moscovici
tout ce qu'ils voulaient savoir au coeur
du pouvoir exécutif savaient le sérieux
de notre enquête
je ne veux pas dire que monsieur
moscovici a été forcément complice d'une
manoeuvre
voulant absolument cacher la vérité
jeudi néanmoins qu'il a mal travaillé
des propos renforcés par l'audition de
michel gonelle lui aussi un rôle clé
dans la sphère l'ancien adversaire
politique de jérôme cahuzac est aussi le
détenteur du fameux enregistrements dès
le 15 décembre il aurait appelé le
directeur adjoint du cabinet de l'élysée
pour confirmer les révélations de
mediapart
j'ai voulu
dire au président de la république
françois hollande ce qui s'était passé
comment ça s'était passé et comment
j'étais sûr de l'origine de ce message
et c'est ce que j'ai expliqué alain
zabulon sa réponse a été de me dire vous
comprenez que c'est une affaire
extrêmement sensible j'ai dit oui c'est
peut-être pas la peine que vous me
disiez j'ai compris que c'est une
affaire sensible
il me dit vous comprendrez que je dois
en référé j'ai dit oui je comprends très
bien que vous deviez en référé il m'a
certifié qu'il allait me rappeler une
vingtaine de personnes seront
auditionnés d'ici juillet dont jérôme
cahuzac lui même manuel valls et pierre
moscovici devrait aussi être entendue
prochainement alors son ami ça commence
eu un peu mal pour le gouvernement ces
auditions on entend fabrice arfi qui dit
tout ce qu'ils voulaient savoir savez
est ce que pierre moscovici a mal
travaillé il peut dire ça comme le dit
edwy plenel j'ai pas je vous n'avez pas
être satisfait ma réponse
il ya une commission denquête elle va
rendre ses conclusion j'ai pu comprendre
au mois deux au moins de septembre c'est
au regard de ces communes ddc conclusion
qu'on pourrait éventuellement faire
l'écho monte à moi j'ai appartenu à des
suivis ces additions non non non ce
débat non parce que quand on est
ministre on est un petit peu de travail
non qu on ne vous suis pas j'ai vu ce
qui était sorti dans les dents dans les
médias mais moi j'ai même moi même
participé des commission denquête
enfants sont tout particulièrement
celles sur les conditions de la
libération des infirmières bulgares
elles étaient publiques mais ce qui
était comme mon ski a été commenté c'est
la fin c'est les conclusions de la
commission
ce qui est intéressant quand même
souligner c'est que cette commission
denquête existe elle est demandée pas
d'opposition ça n'a pas toujours été le
cas comme cela a été rappelé cette
semaine là il faut qu'elle fasse son
travail de manière notamment lille
entend depuis le début de
pas de la majorité oui c'est très bien
qu'elle existât à l'époque leur île
l'ancienne majorité ne le faisait pas ne
serait-ce que ça va durer presque de
boer avoir plus cette commission d
enquête et que pendant ce temps là on ne
va pas cesser de parler de la sphère
québec ça commence à ressembler aux
sparadraps du capitaine haddock pour
vous non c'est vrai que sa part été pour
nous ça a été quand même un choc
moi je sais que je connais qui les
auront kayak depuis on a été député
ensemble 1 en 1997 sur des forcément
parler avec lui
lui-même a toujours affirmé que que bien
entendu ils n'avaient pas donné mais
jamais eu de compte en suisse mais me
met d'ailleurs donc ça va durer très
longtemps cette affaire oui ça va ça va
ça va durer au moins jusqu'au jusqu'aux
conclusions de la commission d'enquêté
dont on peut espérer que une fois ces
conclusions rendues sur le débat public
on en aura fini il y aura toujours après
éventuellement les suites judiciaires
mais ça c'est le rôle c'est drôle de la
justice de toute façon en démocratie
j'ai bien on gagne toujours à la
transparence et donc moi je n'ai pas de
j'ai pas de problème s'il faut parler on
ne reparlera mais on ne pourra le faire
que quand les conclusions seront connues
de médiapart
vous avez été aussi un petit peu mieux
dans l'oeil du cyclone heures par
mediapart qui cette semaine fait état
d'une enquête sur les marchés passés
dans l'essonne qui reviennent notamment
sur un rabais qui vous auraient été
consenties pour une société par une
société d'architectes pour la
construction de votre maison
ça date de 2005 mais ça ressort
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous pouvez
dire puisque cette affaire j'ai pu dire
à l'époque puisqu'il ya déjà eu des
articles au mois de septembre et octobre
donc ce que j'ai dit aux journalistes
mais ça revient parce que médiapart fait
une grande enquête sur ce cas sur
l'essonne où il met en cause le journal
met en cause un architecte et une série
de l'entreprise en mettant en relation
le fait que des des relations entre qui
existerait entre des élus cet architecte
et six entreprises et des marchés
publics qu'ils honte qui ont été
obtenues par cet architecte dans les
communes où il se trouve que simplement
cet architecte lui n'a rien
obtenu ni de ma commune ninon ma
communauté d'agglomération c'est ce que
j'ai dit à mediapart qu'il écrive une
ristourne d'architecte oui mais c'est en
même temps médiapart surtout le
journaliste de médiapart se contredit un
peu puisqu'il ville il publie même la
liste que je lui ai donné des
entreprises qui ont travaillé et les
montants correspondants et on aboutit à
une maison qui a été construite à 4000
euros du mètre carré qui compte tenu de
la situation et même des moments où je
me demandais si c'était pas un chien
pour le coup je me suis pas fait avoir
mais en tout cas on est vraiment tu ne
veux qu'elle doit faire c'est ça non
mais je pense sur le coeur je lui dis
que sur tout ce qui intéresse le
journaliste c'est ce qui aurait pu se
passer en essonne de liens entre des
entreprises et des élus il administre
aussi c'est pour mieux oui bah ça permet
d'asseoir sa part mais peut-être de
faire un peu plus de publicité mais bon
je vais pas je vais pas leur reprocher
parce que je pense que là encore moi je
crois vraiment à l'indépendance de de la
presse dont qu'ils fassent leur travail
par ans exigeait encore plus maintenant
des élus vous pensez que c'est une bonne
chose
oui oui je pense que c'est je pense que
ça correspond à une onde la vie
d'ailleurs quand il a fallu qu'on pollue
notre patrimoine pour nous tous c'était
un peu un peu difficile un peu compliqué
parce qu'on a l'impression de se mettre
à nu on va vous parler de deux de ma
maison depuis depuis que je travaille
mais rentrer c'est un salaire ensuite
ceux des indemnités d'élue gêner plus
qui travaille elle un salaire c'est vers
les conditions de l'hérault cette voie
là ils sont elles sont connues c'est
toujours très très difficile mais je
pense que maintenant c'est une exigence
démocratique
et d'ailleurs on le voit bien quand on a
publié le patrimoine des ministres on a
eu droit au palmarès aux mains et puis
après 6
c'était fini députés et sénateurs
devraient faire la même chose qui
s'engage pas sur ce terrain là oui mais
je crois que je joue dans le cadre des
débats qu'on peut avoir je pense qu'il
commette une erreur
in fine et les citoyens maintenance sont
en demande et je crois que quand on est
on accepte qu'on est un homme public ou
une femme publique il ya des contraintes
supplémentaires message est passé pour
les députés et sénateurs
ils vous répondront à passer au mariage
pour tous est un thème qui divise en ce
moment beaucoup la droite entre ceux qui
veulent l'abrogation du texte ceux qui
veulent réécrire le tout sur fond de
manifestations et de candidature à la
primaire parisienne tam tran huy une
chose est certaine
jean françois copé participera dimanche
à la manif pour tous cette ultime
participation du président de l'uem et
masquent mal les divergences qui agitent
la droite sur l'avenir qu'elle entend
donner à la loi sur le mariage pour tous
au sénat si l'on ne parle pas
d'abrogation on évoque la réécriture de
la loi sera examiné par ce que c'est il
ya tous les aspects
de l'adoption etc qui pose problème
surtout quand on voit ce qui pourrait se
profiler à l'horizon
beaucoup d environ pouvoir je pense que
il y aura sûrement un référendum
d'initiative partagée sur le sujet donc
le problème se posera dans ces termes là
me faudra la réexaminer mais je pense
que il faudra la réexaminer au vu de ce
qui sera donné son obligation
certains sont moins tranchées sur le
sujet car même si jean-claude lenoir a
voté contre le texte du gouvernement
il lui paraît difficile aujourd'hui de
revenir sur cette loi
je ne vois pas comment on pourrait
s'asseoir sur une loi qui a été votée
par une majorité
nous étions dans la minorité et qui a
été validée par le conseil
constitutionnel
en attendant ces différentes approches
ont déjà donné une incidence directe sur
les primaires ump à paris s'étant
abstenu lors du vote au parlement
nathalie kosciusko-morizet a fait hier
l'objet de critiques de la part de
guillaume pelletier le leader de la
droite forte qui a déclaré qu'il ne
souhaitait pas avoir nkm désignée
candidate de l'ump nathalie kosciusko
morizet qui paye un peu le prix fort de
s'être abstenus sur ce texte vous la
soutenez un petit peu dans son combat ou
pas je ne soutiens pas de soutiens aucun
des candidats aux primaires après de
l'ump d'abord je vais dire certaines
choses on est l'ump si très rapidement
mis aux primaires trouve que c'est un
maintenant un exercice démocratique
fantastique comme moi je me suis occupé
de l'organisation de la primaire du
parti socialiste
il avait dénoncé un exercice illégal
antidémocratique je me félicite du coup
il qu'ils s'y mettent
après il ya compte organiser une
primaire il ya un débat entre entre des
candidats il ya des prisons noires et
des prises de position mais il a si j'ai
du mal à comprendre
guillaume pelletier a toujours dit ce
qu'il pensait de la loi pour le sur le
malaise pour tous il considère que non